now how can any of us forget Biden's
refrain about Charlottesville endlessly
repeated for dramatic effect close your
eyes remember what you saw
neo-nazis White
supremacists and the KKK coming out of
the fields coming out of those fields at
night Virginia with lighted torches
their veins bulging veins bulging their
veins bulging chanting the same
anti-semitic bile heard across Europe in
the 30s
well no one on his staff apparently has
told him about the other rallies
happening across the United States
filled with Fanatics with militant
chants glory to the murders
GL glory to the
[Music]
murders long living
def committing
genocide
genocide and just outside of Chicago in
skoki Illinois home of the state
Holocaust Museum we saw some of the more
shocking demonstrations taking place
remember that city was famously the site
of the Neo-Nazi demonstrations that were
at issue in one of the Supreme Court's
seminal First Amendment cases that those
protesting today might wave a different
flag but their target seems to be the
same and instead of purely Free Speech
these ones are engaging in straight
violence hey hey
hey
Hey where's the White House joining me
now piss breeder Christos the man you
saw was just attacked by Pro Palestinian
protesters he's also a college activist
with Turning Point USA Peter first um
how are you doing after that and what
led to that moment thanks for having me
Laura I'm doing a lot better now I do
have bruising on my hands and on my back
as well as a concussion what basically
caused that event was I was at this pro
Israel event and I was going to meet one
of my co-workers outside of the event
and as we met together at his parking
spot we tried to get back into the
pro-israel event but when we went to the
police barricades they denied us entry
so we had to walk all the way back
through a lot of these Pro Palestinian
protesters and at this point the entire
mob already saw that we were pro-israel
so they began following us and they were
screaming at us calling saying that we
were committing genocide calling us
Nazis
and they began kicking my coworker and
as we began to make our way towards the
end of the street we saw an Orthodox
Jewish couple and the mob grew angrier
and started following us and at one
point I just got you know I got
separated from my coworker and it was
just myself and this couple and the next
thing I knew I was punched in the back
of the head pushed into bushes and then
punched repeatedly kicked in the head
and hit with a flag pull uh thankfully
there was a police officer there that
helped me get to safety but the overall
situation was
very very scary um and this is something
that you know we we people who are pro
iseral are subjected to well it seems
like again the White House or Biden or
his uh you know his supporters uh they
seem to have only a focus on one type of
protester and they use that one type of
protester as their vehicle for attacking
all conservatives or anyone whoever
voted for Trump they did that
brilliantly but in this case you're
attack it looks like other people are
harassed who are obviously you know
they're Jewish Americans and yet they're
calling you a Nazi when they clearly
seem to be vehemently anti-israel that
that's just stupid they're just stupid
people at this point you know they were
going to that Orthodox Jewish man in his
wife's face who were older and they were
calling them Nazis as well W and this
lady was shaking yes it was one of the
most craziest things I've ever seen in
my life and this lady was shaking and
trying to pull her camera out to record
and I said Miss don't worry I'm already
recording and all we had to like all I
was worried about in that moment was
just trying to get out get out of that
situation safely um but oh yeah you
could end up with a brain bleed like
Andy no you know when he was attacked
out on the in the Pacific Northwest
against by antifa now given the work
that you do uh with young people at
Turning Point USA why do you think so
many young people are flocking toward
this Pro pales Ian cause and and Hamas
at our at our universities is it just
deeply tied to anti-americanism is it
just more propaganda on social media or
a
combination I think a lot of it is a
lack of research you know I'm not going
to tell anyone what to believe but I do
encourage them to do their research and
I think that a lot of these universities
and their professors who are actively
supporting you know a lot of these bad
things that are happening in Israel are
the reason why a lot of these students
mostly college students are pro
Palestine but you know we are pro peace
we're pro Israel we're pro everything we
want everyone to live safely together
and to love one another because we're
all humans we all bleed but I think a
lot of the students don't want to do the
research or the time and effort and they
kind of want to go with like yeah
they're Peter Peter you're young let me
just tell you the way it is okay it's
not that they're not want to do it they
just they're feeling everyone's emoting
and feeling nobody's thinking and
they're not interested in thinking Peter
thank you hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else